Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir sitzen vor dem Salon.
Und wir reden noch über ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Und zwar fragen wir uns ja schon
längere Zeit, was ist da eigentlich los in den Medien, warum wird über so vieles nicht berichtet?
Ja, wir haben heute Morgen der Livestream des Podcasts, also heute im Sinne
von, wir nehmen ja hier gerade am 1. auf, auch wenn es erst nächste Woche kommt.
Der Livestream oder die Premiere des Videos ist noch nicht mal gestartet und
wir bekommen sofort eine Frage, warum wir die RKI-Files nicht behandelt haben.
Wir werden gleich versuchen, 150 E-Mails von euch mit Claude für uns zusammenzufassen.
KI-Files, keine Ahnung, müssen alles wir machen?
Ich glaube, die RKI-Falls werden doch ausführlich, also nicht in den Massenmedien,
aber daran können wir auch nichts ändern.
Wir sind auch nur ein weiterer Podcast, der sich halt mit dieser Gemengelage
und zu Corona an sich, haben wir schon ganz schön viel gesagt die letzten Jahre, würde ich sagen.
Aber zurück zu den Massenmedien.
Ja, wir fragen uns, warum kommen auch andere Themen selten vor,
zum Beispiel das Thema Armut, wie geht es eigentlich Alleinerziehenden,
wie ist die Situation von Kindern,
wie ist die Situation von Familien und dann ist natürlich immer diese Überlegung,
wer macht eigentlich die Medien und wir wissen, Das sind vorwiegend Leute,
die nicht so diese basalen Probleme haben, sondern wenn da irgendetwas fehlt,
dann kann man jemanden anrufen, der sich darum kümmert.
Zumindest, wenn wir uns die Premium-Journalisten ansehen.
Das sagst du so genau, weil in den Medien arbeiten keine Leute,
die besonders viel Geld verdienen oder eine besonders tolle Herkunft,
Kindheit oder was auch immer.
Naja, also ist es schon so, dass im deutschen Journalismus, wenn man sich da
die Biografien ansieht, es auffällig ist, dass sehr viele aus bürgerlichem Hause
kommen, gut bürgerlichem Hause kommen, Vater Akademiker, Mutter Ärztin.
Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass die mehr als 2500 netto verdienen.
Genau, aber die haben schon mal nicht die große Sorge in ein totales Loch zu
fallen, sondern man erbt schon noch das Vorstadthäuschen.
Bin mir nicht so sicher, aber vielmehr weit.
Das ist schon sehr weit verbreitet. Hinzu kommt, dass die Leute,
die an der Spitze stehen, Anne Will, Markus Lanz und so weiter,
die wirklich die Themen bestimmen dann.
Also dann, wenn sie eine Themenauswahl setzen, auch dafür sorgen,
dass der ganze Diskurs sich darauf konzentriert, die natürlich aller finanziellen
Probleme sich längst entledigt haben.
Zuschauer, die alle kritisieren. Ja,
da hat Wolfgang Micha mal einen sehr guten Text geschrieben bei dem Kanzlerduell damals. Ja.
Vier Journalisten, zwei Kandidaten, sechs Personen im Raum, alle Millionäre
und die klären jetzt, wer für uns die Bundesregierung anfühlt.
Und wir haben ja sehr häufig hier in dem Podcast auch darüber gesprochen,
darüber wie schlecht die Familien dran sind.
Nicht nur in Bezug auf Kindergrundsicherung, sondern generell sind die Aussichten
für junge Leute schlecht.
Deswegen fordern wir ja sowas wie beispielsweise ein Grunderbe.
Wählen ab sieben.
Wir ellen ab sieben. Und nun gab es ja einen Lanz-Precht-Podcast mit Toni Kroos,
der ein bisschen für Furore gesorgt hat, weil Toni Kroos dann sowas sagte,
dass er sich in Deutschland nicht mehr sicher genug fühlt und deswegen auch
nicht zurückkommen will.
Auf diese Debatte gehen wir jetzt nicht ein, die ist ja auch hinreichend bekakelt worden.
Amüsant fand ich aber, dass das Interessanteste, was dort eigentlich gesagt
wurde in diesem Podcast, nicht vorkam. Und das überlegen wir uns jetzt mal,
wie können wir das kontextualisieren mit dem, was ich da eben alles gesagt habe.
Toni, ein Thema, seit langer Zeit merke ich, das ist so unterschwellig immer
da, die Frage der Leistungsbereitschaft und die Frage, die dahinter steht,
sind wir das eigentlich noch?
Sind wir wirklich zum unbedingten Erfolg bereit?
Sind wir sozusagen bereit, uns zu quälen und zwar auch über den Punkt hinaus,
an dem du sagst, ich kann eigentlich nicht mehr und trotzdem gehe ich den entscheidenden Schritt weiter.
Bundesjugendspiele war so das Thema.
Also wir kennen diese Debatte noch, Bundesjugendspiele. soll das weiter so bewertet
werden oder bekommen alle eine Siegerurkunde, was auch immer.
Ich kann dazu nur sagen, dass ich natürlich nie eine Ehrenurkunde bekommen habe.
Ich glaube einmal eine Siegerurkunde und Bundesjugendspiele.
Ich habe dann nachher sehr gut verstanden, mich an diesen Tagen krankschreiben zu lassen.
Aber ich will von mir, von meinem persönlichen Schicksal nichts ableiten und
finde es ja auch schön, wenn Sportlehrer mal arbeiten müssen.
Es war ja immer diese Sache, die Sportlehrer bereiten ein halbes Jahr die Bundesjugendspiele
vor, aber ich will diese Debatte genau nicht führen jetzt.
Sondern … Dann lass mich doch, wenn du es nicht führen willst,
eine Ehrenrettung des Sportlehrers.
Der Sportlehrer steht einer Klasse vor in den Momenten, in denen es darauf ankommt.
Denn wann immer irgendein Comedian heute nochmal bei Conan O'Brien oder wo auch
immer in dem Podcast sitzt, geht es nur um eine Frage. Frage,
wer warst du damals im Sportunterricht als Mannschaften aufgeteilt worden?
Natürlich immer der Letzte auf der Bank. Also wenn eine Sache bleibt in der
Erinnerung eines Menschen aus der Schulzeit,
dann ist es nicht, und damals habe ich Informatik studiert, gelernt und Mathe
war ich super gut oder schlecht oder wie auch immer. Nein, es ist dieser Sportunterricht.
So der Sportlehrer.
Wir können über ihn lächeln, aber der Sportlehrer hat mit die heikelsten Aufgaben,
nämlich eine Klasse zu bändigen und zu motivieren, während sie nicht festgeschnallt
auf Holzstühlen hinter einem Pult in die formalen normativen Zwänge, was auch immer,
ihrer künftigen, wir brauchen dich für unser Erwerbspersonenpotenzial,
lern schon mal diszipliniert zu sein.
Nein, nein, der Sportlehrer hat es mit den heiklen Momenten zu tun.
Und ich denke dabei immer wieder an den Lehrer Schröder, den du vielleicht kennst,
der ja auch eine Halle nach der anderen füllt.
Und dann sitzen vor ihm immer die angehenden Lehrer und er macht Comedy-Programm.
Und dann fragt er das Publikum, wer seid ihr denn?
Und dann melden sich Menschen oder er spricht sie an, wie man das als guter Lehrer macht.
Man spricht sie an, sie melden sich und sagen, ich studiere Lehramt,
was denn? in Mathe und Physik und dann irgendwann im Laufe des Abends ich bin nur Grundschule.
Und das ist der Moment auf YouTube, bitte schaut es euch an,
wo der Herr Schröder einmal kurz in zwei Minuten erklärt, was es bedeutet.
Grundschullehrer zu sein.
Eine ungebändigte Klasse mit absoluter Diversität, Einzugsgebiet,
keine soziale Vorkontrolle, sondern ausgelieferter Realität.
Und so ist das ein bisschen beim Sportunterricht auch. Also die Schule immer
zu reduzieren, auf der Mathe und der Deutschunterricht und da lernt man dann schön und so weiter.
Nein, die Frage ist, glückliche Kinder brauchen einen Sportunterricht, der gelingt.
Und zwar auch dann, wenn sie als Letzte ausgewählt werden, wenn sie auf so einer
Bank sitzen und warten, aufgerufen zu werden. Und wie macht man das?
Beispielsweise, indem man die Situation vermeidet, gar nicht erst herstellt.
Zum Beispiel, aber wir alle werden...
Und alle werden die neue Gesellschaft schon mal lebt,
Auch wenn die Witze in 40 Jahren noch erzählt werden, dass Leute auf einer Bank
und jetzt nähern wir uns dem Bundesjugendspielen und dieser Punktevergabe,
das kann man alles, also ich weiß ja, wie dieser Clip weitergeht,
das nicht mehr zu ertragen.
Nun, du bist also gegen diese Punktevergabe.
Absolut.
Ja, ich halte auch nichts davon und du hast jetzt ein schönes Ideal vom Sportunterricht
beschrieben und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass jetzt die jüngere Generation
von Sportlehrern auch in diese Richtung geht.
Ich kann dir nur aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung sagen, mit sehr vielen Sportlehrern.
Genau, deine eigene Erfahrung. Wie sah das aus?
Man kommt da rein, es ist ja dann irgendwann getrennt, Jungs und Mädels,
dann kommt der Sportlehrer und sagt, und was wollt ihr heute machen?
Und dann wie die Schlafschafe, um es mal ganz deutlich zu sagen,
haben dann so ein paar Jungs gesagt, Fußball.
Daraufhin wurde dann einfach jedes Mal Fußball gespielt.
In Erwartung einer besseren Gesellschaft plädiere ich dafür,
liebe Sportler, lasst euch nicht entmutigen von alten Erfahrungen aus antiker
Zeit, wie du sie jetzt vorgetragen hast oder bei Conan O'Brien reportiert wird.
Nein, der Sportunterricht ist das Einfallstor in den Gemütszustand der kommenden
Generation. Das ist die wichtigste Aufgabe überhaupt.
Für mich war es natürlich toll, ich habe mich mit meinesgleichen,
also mit Leuten, die so ähnlich drauf waren wie ich.
Siehste, das sind die Vorzüge eines gelingenden sozialen Lebens in der Schule.
Absentiert.
Zum Beispiel.
Haben keinen Sporthinterricht gemacht.
Weil der Lehrer euch die Freiräume dafür gegeben hat, statt eisern diszipliniert
euch zu zwingen, aber jetzt vor allem die Kletterwand hochzuklettern.
Sagen wir so, diesem Lehrer ging es jetzt glaube ich nicht um unsere Freiräume,
sondern eher um seine Freiräume, zum Teil auch um mal ein Bierchen zu trinken oder so, alles okay.
Okay, aber ich sage also ganz klar, das war jetzt nicht, das war nicht irgendein
pädagogisches größeres Programm, sondern das war großer Stumpfsinn ausgebreitet auf 90 Minuten.
Dass das anders geht, glaube ich absolut.
Gehen muss.
Wir wollen aber nicht diese Debatte eigentlich führen über die Bundesjugendspiele,
sondern wir sehen schon hier, geht es also um die Leistungsbereitschaft,
der unbedingte Wille zum, und dann gibt es ein kleines Stocken bei Markus Lanz, Erfolg. Erfolg, ja.
Und jetzt fragt er ja hier einen absoluten Spitzenfußballer,
Toni Kroos, sehr, sehr reich.
Wir hören uns doch gar nicht die Antwort von Toni Kroos an, sondern wir überlegen
uns nochmal, wen erleben wir dort?
Also einen wahnsinnig reichen Mann und zwei sehr reiche Männer.
Also Toni Groß natürlich nochmal viel, viel reicher als Markus Lanz und Richard David Precht.
Und wir hören, wie Markus Lanz weiter diese Frage nach der Leistungsbereitschaft
und dem unbedingten Willen zum Erfolg formuliert.
Es gibt dann eigentlich plötzlich nur noch Gewinner. Man ist dann hervorragender
Zweiter und alle sind Sieger.
Und wenn man Letzter geworden ist, dann ist man Erster von hinten.
Es gibt keine Verlierer mehr sozusagen.
Wie schaust du darauf? Das ist ja die Frage, auch weil du selber auch Kinder
hast. Das ist auch etwas, was Richard und mich auch in unserem Leben beschäftigt.
Wie kriegen wir unsere Kinder? Wie kriegen wir die hungrig?
Und das ist das Interessante. Die meisten Menschen in Deutschland stellen sich
die Frage, wie bekommen wir unsere Kinder satt?
Manchmal wirklich ganz existenziell, also reicht das Geld bis zum Ende des Monats,
dass ich noch diese Einkäufe bei Aldi oder Edeka machen kann?
Und dann aber auch die Frage, werde ich es irgendwie schaffen,
ihnen einen Weg zu ermöglichen, dass sie vielleicht einen kleinen Aufstieg haben,
dass sie auch sich irgendwann eine eigene Wohnung nicht kaufen können,
aber dass sie sich die Miete leisten können?
Also es sind wirklich diese Fragen, wird man satt im ganz buchstäblichen Sinne
und im übertragenen Sinne.
Millionäre stellen sich die Frage, jetzt habe ich diese Kinder,
die sind ja auch an sich talentiert und so, diese gehen auf die besten Schulen,
aber die wissen natürlich,
dass sie sich eigentlich niemals anstrengen müssten, weil sie ja eh Millionen
hier erben, immer weich fallen, ihnen wird nichts passieren,
sie werden zehnfach aufgefangen.
Wie kriegt man jetzt diese Kinder noch motiviert?
Ich glaube, dass das tatsächlich für Markus Lanz und Designen ein Problem sein könnte.
Nur, hier sehen wir wieder, das ist
das Problem des oberen Prozents oder vielleicht noch der oberen 3%, ja.
Aber es ist nicht das Problem der Mehrheitsgesellschaft in Deutschland.
Absolut, unterstütze ich voll. Ich finde auch, Scott Galloway hat sich letztens
auch nochmal dazu geäußert, wie man jetzt mit Kindern umgeht,
die man ja am Leben erhalten und fürs Leben vor allem selbst ertüchtigen möchte.
Ich dachte mir dann so, als ich das hörte, im besten Falle garantiert man ihnen
einfach ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen.
Also man zahlt ihnen nicht einfach mit einem Schlag 25 Millionen aus oder so,
sondern man garantiert ihnen einfach ihr Leben lang, dass sie pro Monat,
sagen wir mal, 2000 Euro haben.
Den reichen Kindern.
Genau. Danach den Rest müssen sie selber organisieren. Sie kriegen einfach nur
so eine Dauerrente oder sowas. Und,
Das dann eben auch als politischen Wunsch darüber hinaus formulieren.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ein guter Modus, den man da machen kann.
Alles andere, da fragt man sich nur, wie kriege ich mein Kind hungrig?
Mein Kind ist nicht motiviert genug.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt immer differenzieren, wer spricht da eigentlich
und welche Probleme besprechen die? Besprechen die jetzt ihre Millionärsprobleme?
Dann sind das als Millionärsprobleme sicherlich Probleme, die real sind,
aber nicht real für uns sind.
Oder sind das grundsätzliche Probleme, nämlich der Leistungswille in der Gesellschaft?
Nimmt der vielleicht bei den Rich Kids ab, möglicherweise, weil die ein bisschen
zu viel Instagram geguckt haben und gedacht haben, naja, man kann auch nur in
der Sonne liegen und ins Fitnessstudio gehen, ohne zu arbeiten.
Oder reden wir hier über eine Leistungsgesellschaft von Leuten,
die einfach ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen, damit sie ihre Miete zahlen können.
Und da wird auch gar nicht gefragt, ob die leistungsbereit sind oder nicht, die müssen arbeiten.
Das ist ja auch mal das Interessante, dass so getan wird, als hätte man diese
unglaubliche Möglichkeit, sich auf die faule Haut zu legen, die ja nicht existiert.
Also die existiert im Kopf von Carsten Dinnemann, aber sonst nirgends.
Ja genau, und immer wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt, die können sich doch aussuchen,
wo sie arbeiten, es sind doch überall Stellen frei, dann muss man immer sagen,
ja genau, aber sie müssen dann für zwei arbeiten und das, was sie sich kaufen
wollen, kostet viermal so viel.
Also man kann sich durchaus aussuchen, wo man arbeitet für seine 1900 netto oder sowas.
Ja, das ist, ja, wenn ich solche Clips jetzt höre, im Kontext unserer heutigen
Lektüren würde ich eh sagen,
manchmal wird man schon so ein bisschen JD Vance im Kopf und denkt sich,
was für eine von einem Zentralregime gesteuerte Matrix ist das eigentlich,
indem uns Markus Lanz fragt, wie wir unsere Kinder hungrig kriegen. Ja.
Sollte man da nicht mal eine große Atombombe reinwerfen, so ungefähr,
ja? So eine politische Atombombe.
Und punktuell kann man damit durchaus sympathisieren, aber wir bauen heute mal
das Bild zusammen. Also wir lesen diesen Vanity Fair Text zum Beispiel.
Ich will überleiten zum Buch, wenn dir das recht ist, über das wir heute sprechen.
Wir reden ja über Unhaltbarkeit auf dem Weg in eine andere Moderne von Ingolfur Blüthorn.
Ich habe 16 Seiten Notizen, heute wird es fundamental.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
Das ist gut. Lehrreich.
Lehrreich, okay.
Ja, ich habe im privaten Kreis schon gemeint, ja, wir lesen so ein Buch,
das finde ich wieder nicht so gut.
Dann kam die Rückfrage, ist das denn gut, ein Buch zu lesen,
das man nicht so gut findet?
Ich meinte dann, typischerweise suchen wir schon so Sachen aus,
die wir irgendwie von sich aus lehrreich finden.
Aber auch in schlechten Büchern steckt ja mehr drin, als der Autor wollte,
sondern es ist ja immer ein Angebot, darüber hinaus zu lesen und Denkangebote zu machen.
Und da wir jetzt, glaube ich, nach Selk jetzt bei ihm, und ich habe noch so
irgendwas im Hinterkopf, das dritte Mal, finde ich, in so einer,
Falle laufen. Falschen Denkens. Falschen politischen Denkens.
Es ist keine Falle und es ist auch kein falsches politisches Denken und es ist
ja ganz interessant, dass du das jetzt gerade betonst, dass man auch aus Büchern,
die eigentlich nicht so toll sind, was rausziehen kann.
Das ist ja etwas, was der Autor selbst macht. Er liest nämlich Ulrich Beck und
schaut sich an, wo er eigentlich geirrt hat, kann aber aus diesen Irrtümern
dann sehr viele neue Erkenntnisse über uns ableiten.
Aber wir gehen jetzt gleich in die Diskussion. Ich will was anderes machen,
um ein bisschen Fundament zu liefern.
Wir alle wissen, dass Selbstverwirklichung das große Credo ist und Diversity ganz, ganz wichtig ist.
Und wir bekommen es laufend serviert. Und ich habe das jetzt nochmal so in Nutsche
gesehen, ganz zufällig in einer Krombacher Werbung für das Getränk Spezi.
Das ist so eine Mischung aus Cola, Limo. Ich habe es noch nie getrunken.
Es soll auch keine Werbung dafür sein. Ich verspreche, ich werde es auch niemals trinken.
Aber wir hören uns jetzt mal diesen kurzen Clip an.
Normal? Gibt's das heute noch? Jeder von uns ist doch irgendwie anders. Besonders.
Eben einzigartig. Auf Speziellsein. Kronbacher Spezi. Spezi statt normal.
Nicht normal, speziell sein, jeder ist anders. Ist das die Diagnose von Reckwitz,
die Gesellschaft der Singularitäten?
Oder geht das sogar noch weiter? Dass also diese sich nicht einordnen wollen
mehr in irgendetwas, also völlig individualistisch zu sein, dass das eigentlich
eine neue Grundlage ist, auf der wir alle stehen oder ein sehr wackeliger Boden,
der dazu führt, dass ein größeres Projekt, wie zum Beispiel ein ökologisches Projekt,
wo schon auch die kollektive Ansprache wichtig ist, nicht mehr gelingen kann.
Das ist ja eine der Fragen, die sich Blüthorn stellt in seinem Buch und das
finde ich hier nochmal in wunderbarer Weise präsentiert, dass wir es mit einer
sehr starken Vereinzelung zu tun haben,
die sich dann auch rein konsumistisch ausdrückt und,
Und diesen Subjektivitäten, die sich rein konsumistisch ausdrücken und sich
aber auch so tatsächlich selbst verwirklichen, zumindest in Teilen,
denen soll man jetzt zugleich sagen,
dass Verzicht wichtig ist. Kann das gelingen?
Ich denke, es funktioniert nicht und zugleich ist man aber darauf angewiesen,
diese Selbstverwirklichung auch weiterhin bestehen zu lassen.
Und das ist ja die Dialektik, in die man dann hineinkommt, die Blüthorn in seinem Buch beschreibt.
Ja, also hier ist jetzt auch ganz wichtig zu fragen, wer spricht,
so wie du es ja eben schon für eigentlich alle Themen markiert hast. ist.
Der Blühdorn ist ein Boomer. Das wird gleich eine Rolle spielen.
Auch bei der Frage, welche Literatur wählt er aus, um uns nochmal zu verdeutlichen, woran er denkt.
Hier bei dieser Werbung, denke ich mir, die ist gemacht für eine werberelevante
Zielgruppe, die unser Alter ist.
40-Jährige. Ich bin nicht 40. Naja, ich sag mal so, unter 50, über 35.
Ich weiß, es kommt immer so jung.
Guck dir nochmal das an. Also wir haben hier eine Ende-20-jährige Frau,
die mit einem coolen Ton zu uns spricht.
Genau, so. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht,
dass die Ansprache hier in Peergroup erfolgt, denn man muss jetzt fragen,
wer fühlt sich von ihr repräsentiert, selbst wenn er weiß,
ich greife hier, ich fresse ein bisschen über den Zaun. Ich gehöre eigentlich gar nicht dazu.
Und gerade Reckwitz hat ja auch dieses Juvenile-Publikum, das eigentlich Teenager-Alter-Kinder
hat, so wie ich, aber sich selber noch im Kopf wie ein Teenager fühlt.
Und es würde, ich könnte dir zustimmen schon deshalb, weil Spezi doch eher auch
was ist, was Ältere trinken, oder? Oder? Das trinkt ein 17-jähriger Spezi?
Dass dieses Getränk Spezi heißt, liegt einfach nur daran, dass man eine Trinkgewohnheit
von Menschen, die man heute ansprechen will, die die vor 20 Jahren hatten, nochmal reaktiviert.
Keiner käme heute auf die Idee, ein Getränk für diese Altersgruppe,
wie wir die Werbepersonen sehen, Spezi zu nennen. Das ist wirklich, das ist kurz vor Cringe.
Diese Getränke heißen anders. So, und ich erinnere immer wieder dran,
das ist eine meiner Lieblingspointen, die Apple Watch,
mit ihren Sturzerkennungen nochmal gucken, ob Vorhof flimmern und so weiter,
ist es nicht für die 20-Jährigen Sportler, die du in der Werbung siehst,
für die Apple Watch, sondern das ist für deren Eltern, die 40-Jährigen,
die sich fragen, ob die Oma nicht mal so eine Uhr tragen sollte.
Das kann man natürlich, wenn man es einfach nur ästhetisch aus der Werbung herausliest,
nicht herauslegen. Man sieht es einfach nicht.
Also du meinst, man müsste eigentlich in beige gekleidete ältere Herren im Biergarten
zeigen, die jetzt sagen, ein Spezi bitte.
Ja, Spezi ist mit dem Reisebus in Urlaub fahren, endlich mal ohne den Mann und
so, mit den Girls, mit den Freundinnen nochmal ein schönes Wochenende haben,
die Tochter vertrösten, die schon vor zehn Jahren ausgezogen ist,
am Handy mit, ja, mach ich und so, und sich dann im Biergarten setzen und die Spezi bestellen.
Also hier ist...
Ja, aber das widerspricht ja nicht meiner These, dass Dass wir hier eine Gesellschaft sehen,
die also ein emanzipatorisches Versprechen an ein Produkt knüpft und zugleich
aber keine Kollektivität mehr herstellt, sondern sich nur als vereinzelt wahrnimmt
und auch verstehen will und damit ein kollektives Projekt,
wie zum Beispiel das Projekt Ökologie, eher nicht machbar ist,
weil jeder erstmal sagt, ja ich bin anders oder das gehört halt auch zu meiner Ausdrucksform,
dies und das zu machen, zum Beispiel in den Urlaub zu fliegen.
Und da habe ich jetzt eine andere Leseart, denn deswegen mein Generationenaufschlag
hinsichtlich älterer Altersgruppen, also Boomer schreiben uns politische Denkbücher,
die wir heute besprechen,
das ist Millennials machen für Millennials Werbung und jetzt mein Punkt,
den ich machen wollte, diese Individualisierung, die da drin steckt,
sehe ich bei den heute jungen Menschen und ich nehme jetzt die 14-Jährigen nicht.
Die sehen alle gleich aus. Und zwar nicht so wie man früher,
da sind die Hipster, da sind die Punker und da noch so ein paar Neonazis oder
so, sondern nein, alle sehen gleich aus.
14-jährige Mädchen, heute helle bis weiße Turnschuhe.
Jogginghose, grau, bauchfrei, weißes Top.
Alle. Manchmal ein schwarzes Top. Manchmal eine schwarze Jogginghose.
So, wenn du dir die Taylor Swift-Konzerte anschaust, siehst du da irgendwen,
der sich voll krass individualisieren möchte und sich dafür schämt,
irgendwie zu einer größeren Gruppe zu gehören, dieselbe Musik wie alle zu genießen?
No. Es gibt da nie ein Mainstream.
Es gibt überhaupt erstmal wieder ein Mainstream. Es gab das lange nicht,
aber jetzt ist es wieder da.
Und gerade jetzt im Juli, wir hatten Europameisterschaft, Taylor Swift Konzerte, der ganze Kram.
Das sind keine Individualisierungs, ich bin nochmal der Einzelgänger und trinke
eine Spezies oder so, sondern das sind neue Kollektivierungen, die da stattfinden.
Von denen ich glaube, die muss man nur sozusagen anpiksen und dann wären die
auch politisch mobilisierbar.
Denn eins der großen Sachen, insbesondere bei den 14-Jährigen,
Subkutan ist mein Verständnis, meine Lesart, wenn ich die so sehe und ich sehe
viele, die wissen, dass sie ausgeliefert sind.
Also nicht nur einer ökologischen Wahrheit, die uns selbst Blüthorn jetzt aus
Boomersicht nochmal unmissverständlich klar macht,
die uns Precht unmissverständlich klar macht, die uns jeder unmissverständlich
klar macht und gleichzeitig sehen wir jeden Tag in den Nachrichten,
wieder wurde nichts getan,
es ist wieder der heißeste Sommer und so weiter und so fort.
Also das ist ein Ausgeliefert sein und ein, ich kann mich, also ich darf jetzt
nicht irgendwelche Wege einschlagen, um mich hier dann auch noch alleine zu
fühlen, weil ich glaube, das ist cool.
Ich glaube, der Zeitgeist ist gerade anders.
Es gibt also einen Anpassungsdruck, der sicherlich darin auch zu sehen ist,
dass es nicht mehr diese Einzelgruppierungen gibt, auch nicht mehr solche Jugendbewegungen,
sondern dass man sich im Mainstream versammelt.
Aber zugleich sind das ja dann Zeichen ohne Inhalt.
Also das ist ja das Ding auch bei Taylor Swift, dass sie es ja nicht mit einem
Inhalt füllt, zum Beispiel mit einem politischen Inhalt.
Man ahnt so ein bisschen, ja, wie wird das wohl sein, wird sie sich noch zu
Kamala Harris äußern oder nicht, aber ich halte es zum Beispiel auch für absolut
möglich, dass sie Republikanerin ist.
Sie wird das nicht sagen, sie wird das andere auch nicht sagen,
sie funktioniert ja wie ein Container, in den man ganz viel selbst so reinlegen
kann und man kann sich dort verbinden.
Also sie ist nicht zum Beispiel Beyoncé, die viel klarer ist,
was Politisches anbelangt.
Das funktioniert deshalb so gut, deswegen können sich ja auch junge Unionsmitglieder,
Ricarda Lang und die radikale Linke und weiß ich nicht, Alt und Jung,
dahinter vereinen, dass sie alle zu Taylor Swift pilgern.
Das ist bei anderen Stars schon wieder anders, da gibt es schon wieder Differenzierung.
Harry Styles beispielsweise spricht jetzt eher nicht ein konservatives Spektrum an.
Taylor Swift, das sieht man ja auch an ihrer Partnerwahl, greift dieses sehr
amerikanisch-konservative Publikum auch noch sehr gut mit ab und das funktioniert
aber nur, wenn man Zeichen ohne Inhalt bleibt.
Sobald sie jetzt anfangen würde, konkret politisch dies oder das einzufordern,
was sie ja machen könnte,
würde das sofort sich auflösen, denn dann gäbe es auch dort eine Spaltung innerhalb
der Taylor Swift Community oder eine Absentierung einiger, die sagen,
dann ist das nicht mehr meine Taylor Swift.
Ich versuche jetzt ein Argument über Bande.
In der Hoffnung, dass ich verstanden werde. Ich bin gespannt,
also schickt gerne mal Nachrichten dazu.
Weil das interessiert mich tatsächlich, denn ich habe ja in der Alten Republik
darüber geschrieben, wie es keine Jugendkultur mehr gibt.
Schon allein, weil man sich ökonomisch ausgeliefert sieht und eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft
mit seinen Eltern ist, man kann sich gar nicht von ihnen lossagen.
Irgendwer muss ja das Taylor Swift-Ticket bezahlen.
Was übrigens nicht bedeutet, dass das jenseits des Individualismus dann ist.
Bei Taylor Swift entsteht keine Kollektivität.
Das ist ja genau das, was die Werbung hier ist. Die Werbung ist ja eigentlich
wie Taylor Swift. Die sagt, jeder ist anders, wir sind doch alle speziell.
Das ist ja an nichts geknüpft, das ist ja reine Zeichensetzung.
Speziell, besonders, anders.
Ja, was soll denn das heißen? Wenn man das jetzt noch zeigen würde,
wenn man jetzt Punker zeigen würde oder Neonazis und würde sagen,
sind alle anders. Nein, nein, es wird natürlich nicht mit irgendetwas weg.
Und deswegen ist also diese Individualisierung, dieser Wunsch danach immer noch
extrem hoch, zugleich dieser Anpassungsdruck, ich muss irgendwie dazugehören,
sonst gehe ich ganz verloren.
Also ich werde das jetzt anders charakterisieren und dann eine Frage in den Raum stellen,
bei der mich interessieren würde, wie unsere Hörer darüber denken und dann auch
sozusagen eine Sammlung an diesen, du hast ja gesagt, das ist so ohne Inhalt
keine Zeichen, sondern das ist so ein Sammelbecken für alles.
Ich halte Taylor Swift inhaltlich für 100% super eindeutig, absolut kongruent
mit diesem progressiven Mainstream.
Bei dem man sich überhaupt nicht mehr die Frage stellt, ob hier irgendwo noch
Anknüpfungspunkte an das ist, was wir bei Donald Trump im politischen Programm sehen, bei J.D.
Vance in der Ideologiegestaltung oder wie auch immer. Also für mich ist das
ein Graben, der ist so groß wie die Erde, ist ein kalter Planet und die Sonne
brennt 3000 Grad heiß. So, das ist der Unterschied.
Die Frage, die ich mir jetzt stelle, ist nicht, wann äußert sich Taylor Swift explizit?
Denn sie hat sich, wie ich eben meinte, im Prinzip so deutlich positioniert
und markiert das auch über wen heißt sie in ihrem Publikum willkommen.
Kommen, alle jungen, weiblichen, bunten, wie auch immer Menschen und so,
dass wirklich jeder einzelne da auffallen würde, der da nicht reinpasst.
Und es traut sich auch niemand mit einem Mager-Cap oder so in so ein Konzert zu gehen.
Die Frage ist jetzt nicht, wann äußert sich Taylor Swift explizit,
weil wenn sie sich explizit äußern würde, wäre das für mich viel schwächer in
der Wirkmächtigkeit in der Politik als dieses implizite Feld,
das sie jetzt bereitet hat.
Was ich mich frage ist, wann äußern sich die Republikaner explizit gegen Taylor Swift?
Und was bedeutet das eigentlich? Weil meine Lesart gerade ist,
dieser Trevor Kelsey und nicht nur er, sondern seine ganze Mannschaft.
Die haben ein neues Männlichkeitsbild, das unvereinbar ist mit dem,
was wir von J.D. Vance heute propagiert bekommen. Unvereinbar.
Nur die 50 größten Fernsehereignisse in Amerika, in der amerikanischen Geschichte, sind Football-Spiele.
Wo diese Leute die Protagonisten sind.
Platz 49 von diesen 50 Plätzen ist nochmal die Mondlandung. Aber ansonsten,
49 dieser 50 größten Fernsehereignisse in der amerikanischen Geschichte sind Football Games.
Aber wieso meinst du neues Männlichkeitsbild? Ich sehe da zwei Meter große,
100 Kilo schwere Männer mit großen Bärten.
Ich weiß noch genau, dass ich dir dieses Reel geschickt habe,
wie die zum Superbowl einmarschiert sind.
Kelsey, super glitzernd in so einem, ich glaube schon selbststrahlendem Anzug.
Die anderen, wo man es richtig sieht, die laufen mit 75.000 Euro teuren T-Shirts da irgendwie rum.
Aber das ist kein, also ich würde sagen, das deckt sich zum Beispiel mit den
Erfahrungen, die ich gemacht habe, wenn ich über die Köhe spazieren gehe.
Ja, aber das deckt sich nicht mit republikanischen Parteitagen,
nicht mit den Männlerbildern von J.D. Vance, die er propagiert.
Die deckt sich nicht mit gar nichts.
Das ist zum Beispiel keinerlei Queerness dort. Absolut.
Die sehen alle aus wie Helmsteins.
Die sind sehr gepflegt.
Die laufen bauchfrei rum und so.
Das müssen wir doch mal ästhetisch genau anschauen.
Ob das wirklich der Fall ist.
David Beckham hat damals diese neue Metrosexualität reingebracht und die wird da gerade ausgelebt.
Also wenn ich mir diese Spiele anschaue und wie sie sich geben,
ist das eben nicht dieses martialische und die Blacks irgendwas hier aus Neuseeland
machen nochmal so einen Tanz oder sowas, sondern nee, da stehen die alle staunend
davor und fragen, was ist das denn? Ah ja, haben wir mal im Fernsehen gesehen.
Sondern das ist schon neu. Also für mich ist nicht die Frage,
wann äußert sich Taylor Swift explizit, sondern also impliziter kann man es,
deutlicher kann man es gar nicht machen, so wie sie es implizit macht.
Ich frage mich, wann zeigen die Republikaner, Wann sind sie mutig genug, diese Grenze zu ziehen?
Und von da aus kommen die Signale. Und dann verprellen sie sich aber quasi mit allen.
Du siehst immer jetzt auf Trump und Vance und siehst da diese zwei weißen Männer,
die auch noch solche Positionen vertreten, wie sie solche weißen Männer,
die so aussehen, vertreten.
Vergiss nicht, wie bunt die Republikaner sind.
Vergiss nicht, wie sehr die Republikaner verortet sind, auch in einem Latino-Völler-Kreis.
Nicht mehr, nicht mehr.
Doch, die Republik, also ich kann dir noch ein anderes Beispiel geben.
Wo war der Barbie-Film? Auch wahnsinnig viel gesehen in den Kinos.
Wo war der ungeheuer erfolgreich?
In republikanischen Staaten. Also das heißt, es gibt auch bei den Republikanern
einen Power-Feminismus,
der nicht der wahre Feminismus ist, so was ich darunter verstehe,
aber die verstehen sich auch als Power-Frauen.
Das heißt, diese Buntheit, die massenmedial stattfindet bei diesen großen Events
wie Superbowl oder sonst was, das ist absolut auch bei den Republikanern akzeptiert.
Es geht nur dann ins Politische, was sie nicht wollen, wenn daraus irgendeine
Belehrung folgt. Also wenn dann natürlich Leute aufstehen und sagen,
und ich bin für queere Rechte und so weiter, dann blockieren natürlich die Republikaner immer.
Aber die reine Repräsentation dieser Buntheit, die Republikaner lieben Las Vegas.
Ja, Las Vegas ist eine große Travestieshow, wenn man so möchte.
Ja, also das geht beides sehr gut zusammen und gerade diese Neurechten, die sich dort,
auch denk an Milo Yiannopoulos und so,
das sind ja keine Leute, die einfach nur mit der Magerkappe auf dem Sofa sitzen
und ein weißes Amerika sich herbeisehnen. Es ist schon bunter.
Ja, um das, was ich jetzt gesagt habe, zu sehen, muss man, glaube ich,
ganz eng in der Gegenwart und am Zeitgeist sein.
Ja, dieser Milo mit seiner griechischen Herkunft, schwulen Lebensweise,
bunten Haaren und so weiter, das ging.
Hast du ihn gesehen die letzten fünf Jahre? Ich nicht. Er ist nicht mehr präsent.
Moment, der Republikaner-Parteitag jetzt, den Trump veranstaltet hat,
war der erste, in dem keine Gruppe für, und das sind unsere Latinos,
mehr vorgesehen war in dem Saal.
Die standen in der Daily-Show in diesem Foyer und haben den Scherz gemacht,
zu zweit, sag mir Bescheid, wenn du den ersten Schwarzen siehst,
der nicht hier arbeitet.
Und der Running Gag ist natürlich, die kürzen da eine halbe Stunde Video zusammen,
weil da niemand mehr ist.
Trump war gestern, also wir sind jetzt eine Woche spät, aber gestern bei dieser
Veranstaltung der schwarzen Journalisten.
Selten war er so konfrontativ. Selten hat er so drauf geschissen.
Selten war er so unhöflich und frech und hat dort ein Bullshit erzählt,
dass selbst Fox News heute Morgen dann einfach nur, wir haben das auch nicht
verstanden, wir können das hier nicht erklären.
Das sind jetzt andere Zeiten. Das ist nicht mehr diese George W.
Bush macht auch was für die Schwarzen und so. Nein, das ist jetzt,
jetzt werden hier wirklich die Trennlinien gezogen.
Und da ist Taylor Swift und Trevor Kelsey und ihr ganzes Publikum und so weiter,
gehört nicht innerhalb, da sind auch keine Anknüpfungspunkte,
sondern die Linien werden gerade ganz, ganz hart gezogen.
Ich verstehe das auch nicht so richtig, warum das so ist, weil die Logik sagt
auch, es ist ein Wahlkampf, die müssten doch eigentlich nochmal die Fühle ausstrecken,
aber diese ideologische Radikalisierung und absolute Segregation,
die da stattfindet gerade,
ist wirklich beeindruckend und auch historisch beispiellos, selbst für Amerika.
Also da können wir 80 Jahre zurückgehen, dann finden wir sowas vielleicht wieder
in Gesetzesnormen ausgedrückt.
Aber das, was wir da jetzt gerade sehen, ist, also das kann man nicht aus,
und jetzt lesen wir mal einen 40 Jahre alten Backtext oder so,
das hilft uns da nicht weiter bei sowas.
Also das ist wirklich beeindruckend und ich finde es auf der einen Seite so,
inhaltlich furchterregend, auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir aber,
naja, aber besser als abseits kann man sich gar nicht selber schießen.
Also es ist wirklich grotesk, Was wird er sehen?
Vornehmen. Und hier Ist es dann, wenn du da recht hast in deiner Beschreibung,
tatsächlich so eine weiße, suprematistische Ideologie,
die sich jetzt dort durchdrückt, was ganz den anderen Bewegungen widerspricht,
die jetzt gerade sonst so da sind?
Die fangen gerade an, Vance abzulehnen, weil er eine Frau hat mit indischen Wurzeln.
Wie soll der denn eine amerikanische Familie repräsentieren? So, Vance selber.
Zählt schon nicht mehr in diesen, das kennt man in Deutschland so ein bisschen.
Und nimmt ihm übel, dass er befreundet ist mit einer Transperson oder war.
Sowas zum Beispiel, genau. Dass er dann auch I love you unter 10 E-Mails schickte,
bevor die New York Times hat ja dann das große Text.
Also wir haben in Deutschland dieses Phänomen, dass wir so AfD-Wähler haben
und wir denken, okay, das ist ein echtes Problem und dann gibt es noch die AfD-Funktionäre
und dann gibt es aber so versprengte Gruppen von Ultranationalisten,
die in der Sächsischen Schweiz sitzen und sagen, die AfD, habt ihr eine Meise?
Das ist doch die Altpartei, die ja alles kaputt macht.
Wir hatten doch eine ganz andere Idee. Und jetzt kommen die und biedern sich
da wieder an und lassen sich im Bundestag wählen. Ich will doch hier einen Kampf und so weiter führen.
Und diese Art von Ultranationalismus, die nicht so sehr als Nationalismus ausgelebt
wird, sondern so als ideologisches, die Familie, die sich wieder behauptet gegen
den Staat, gegen die Organisation. Natürlich muss der Mann alleine in der Lage sein.
Die einzige Aufgabe, die der Staat hat, ist zu garantieren, dass die Frau nicht
arbeiten muss und der Mann genug Gehalt hat.
Alles andere ist mir egal und so. Also diese Art von Ultra, und jetzt ist das
Wort noch zu finden, diese Art von Ultra-Ideologie, die da gerade ausgelebt
wird, die ist nicht mehrheitstauglich,
aber sie haben sich durch eine historisch falsche Beobachtung in einem Aufwind
gesehen, leben das jetzt also aus und verprellen aber alle.
Also für Donald Trump ist es gerade,
aus seiner Wahlkampfsicht eine ganz schwierige Situation eigentlich.
Und das jetzt zu beobachten, ich habe ja im letzten Podcast schon gesagt,
ich finde es erstmal lustig, wie der erste Aufschlag dem Einheitsgebieten nur Humor ist.
Weil man dann einfach sagt, also wir sind die Lustigen, ihr seid weird. Du hast es ja betont.
Das ist ja erstmal nur der erste Aufschlag. Mal gucken, was dann kommt.
Wir lesen heute den Vorschlag von Ezra Klein, den er macht, den ich einfach
spektakulär finde, wie jetzt Kamala Harris so einen Wahlkampf gestalten kann.
Und ja, ich würde sagen, das Interessanteste der nächsten Monate bis zur Wahl ist eben.
Wie, also nicht die Ideologie, sondern wie wird sie radikalisiert,
wie kriegt sie Traktion, welche praktische Intelligenz steckt es bei Peter Thiel
dahinter, seine Erweiterung, seine Extension,
die er jetzt bis in den Vizepräsidentschaftskandidatur rein manövriert hat,
Er wird davon lockerlassen müssen. Also nicht nur, weil eventuell er die ganze
Wahl einfach nicht gewinnt, sondern weil sie schon vorher merken,
dass diese Strategie nicht aufgeht.
So, können die da lockerlassen? Wenn sie nicht lockerlassen wollen,
wie extrem gestalten sie dann ihren Wahlkampf und so weiter?
Das sind so diese interessanten Fragen.
Aber die Linien selbst sind wirklich, also die werden gerade so krass gezogen.
Eine Anmerkung noch zu Kamala Harris, weil sich jetzt sehr viele Linke in sie verlieben.
Ja, sie ist nicht Trump und das ist in der Tat ein großer Vorteil,
aber was wir hier eigentlich sehen können, ist eine fatale Situation,
vielleicht die fatalste, in der sich die amerikanische Linke überhaupt in den
letzten 10, 15 Jahren befunden hat.
Es war nämlich eine Zeit lang so, dass zwar immer Establishment-Kandidaten am
Ende aufgestellt wurden, Clinton,
Hillary Clinton oder Biden, aber es gab dann Sanders,
es gab damit so eine linke Stimme, die als Contra dort war und die man irgendwie
auch dann inkludieren musste und Biden hat ja durchaus eine linke Wirtschaftspolitik betrieben.
Das alles stellt sich als Frage jetzt kaum noch oder gar nicht mehr.
Kamala Harris ist eine sehr zentristische Kandidatin mit dem Versprechen, nicht Trump zu sein.
Könnte sie es schaffen? Aber die Debatten, also innerlinke Debatten,
wie müssten eigentlich die Demokraten sich verändern?
Wie müsste die soziale Frage wieder mehr in den Mittelpunkt gerückt werden?
All das wird nicht kommen.
Das heißt, es ist also die totale Verwaltung und ich würde so weit gehen,
das Abfeiern des Status Quo mit Kamala Harris.
Ja, noch einmal, das ist besser als
Trump, aber wir sind in einer fatalen Situation, wo also überhaupt kein….
Ein progressives soziales wirtschaftliches Projekt mehr denkbar oder möglich ist.
Es wird keine Limitierung der Tech-Konzerne geben mit Kamala Harris,
es wird keine Steuern für Reiche geben, es wird keine Umverteilung geben,
es wird nicht wesentlich mehr für Arme geben.
Es geht um ein paar legalistische Dinge, die durchaus wichtig sind,
zum Beispiel in Bezug auf Abtreibungsrechte, aber es geht nicht mehr sonst um
eine irgendwie wirtschaftlich links geartete Politik.
Und damit sind wir an eigentlich einem sehr fatalen Punkt angekommen,
der ja vergleichbar ist mit dem, was wir auch in Deutschland beobachten können,
dass es keine Kraft gibt,
die nennenswert wäre,
die gegen diesen Ampel-Mainstream, der überhaupt nicht links ist,
irgendetwas bewirken könnte.
Es ist, wir dürfen halt den Blick nicht verstellen durch dieses,
ah ja, wir haben einen SPD-Bundeskanzler und die Demokraten vielleicht eine
Präsidentin, denn die stehen halt Vetocracy vor, wie Fukuyama das nannte.
Im Bundestag braucht man halt eine FDP, damit man eine Mehrheit hat,
aber damit die FDP dann, wie sie glaubt, damit sie nicht untergeht,
macht sie halt bei allem Veto.
Joe Biden hatte vorgeschlagen, Kindergeld, völlig neue Idee für Amerika,
Pflegezuschüsse, der ganze Kram, es ging um Trillionen, also in unserem Maße Billionen von Dollar.
Aber der Senat hatte eine 50-50 und man hätte halt die John-Mansion-Stimme gebraucht
und er hat sie ihm nie gegeben. Es wurde alles zerschossen.
Alle Corona-Aufbau-Programme und so weiter, alles zerschossen wurden.
Die einzige Idee, die sie dann noch hatten, war dieser Inflation Reduction Act.
Dann haben sie einfach alles da reingebaut.
Die Republikaner haben wieder alles rausgenommen, was sie nicht drin haben wollten
und dann hat man friss oder stirb genommen, was man kriegen konnte.
Und jetzt schenkt man halt den großen Konzernen Geld dafür, dass sie mit erneuerbaren
Energien irgendwas machen.
Also, selbst wenn jetzt Bernie Sanders oder wer auch immer mit der besten Idee
ever, man steht sich da strukturell einfach im Schach gegenseitig.
Und da ist nichts zu erwarten.
Wieder mal ein Argument mehr, auf die Verfahren zu schauen und nicht auf die
Intentionen der Beteiligten. So wie der Supreme Court sagt, wenn der Präsident
etwas tut, hinterfragen wir die Motive nicht.
Wir verbieten es den Juristen geradezu, die Motive zu hinterfragen.
So kann man jetzt grundsätzlich mal die Motive ausblenden und sich einfach unterm
Strich zählt, was ich oder die anderen nach Adam Too's Pragmatismus fragen.
Ja, was kommt denn am Ende raus? Und dauert nicht so lange.
Und da, ich habe ja schon das letzte Mal den Podcast dafür geworben,
als du meintest, wir sollten jetzt mehr auf die Inhalte schauen. Warum denn?
Nein, nicht auf Inhalte warten, nicht auf Programme, die geschrieben werden warten.
Es ist jetzt nur wichtig, dass nicht Donald Trump Präsident wird und danach
muss halt diese Art von Druck, die man so erzeugt, damit der eine oder der andere
in dieses Amt kommt, muss dann halt weitergehen. Das ist der einzige Weg.
Und da gleichen sich ehrlicherweise beide Seiten, denn so wie die Republikaner,
diese neuen Republikaner, nicht MAGA, nicht QAnon, sondern dieses neue,
sagen wir scheißen auf die alte Verfassungslogik, so ist das halt dann da auch.
Wenn keine Mehrheit im Senat da ist, ist keine Mehrheit im Senat da.
Aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass man für seine Sachen nicht einsteht
und dann halt Druck erzeugt.
In der Hoffnung, dass irgendwann mal eine Mehrheit da ist oder wie auch immer.
Die Republikaner haben sich auch Jahrzehnte Zeit genommen, um eine Mehrheit
im Supreme Court zu haben und dann hatten sie die halt irgendwann. Und in der Hinsicht,
wir müssen über Politik neu nachdenken. Nicht den alten Strukturen und Ideen
nachjammern, wie wir das gleich machen.
Nee, es wird doch gar nicht bei ihm nachgejammert. Wir reden also über Unhaltbarkeit
auf dem Weg in eine andere Moderne von Ingolfur Blüthorn.
Alle merken, es wird heiß, diese Diskussion.
Ganz kurz der Hinweis, wir haben ja einen Preisanstieg, einen kleinen angekündigt.
Steady hat uns dazu, sagen wir, überredet.
Steady ist schuld.
Jedenfalls gibt es also einen Preisanstieg, der wird aber erst am 24.
August kommen. Das heißt, bis dahin kann man sich noch den alten Preis für den Salon sichern.
Das heißt, ab 2,50 Euro im Monat kann man den Salon hören.
Dann ab dem 24. August kostet es dann 3 Euro, wenn man dann dieses Jahresabo abschließt.
Man hat jetzt im August auch noch die besondere Freude, den Sommersalon dann
zu hören, also für alle, die nicht kommen.
Ist ja so gut wie ausverkauft dann in Frankfurt.
Noch ein Hinweis da, weil manchmal Leute kommen dort und sagen,
ob wir Bücher verkaufen. Nein, wir verkaufen selbst keine Bücher dort,
also wir haben da keinen Büchertisch stehen.
Wir signieren gerne Bücher, dann müsst ihr die nur vorher euch kaufen oder mitbringen.
Und ich habe noch ein paar da. Ich kann 10 mitbringen, aber 100 Euro das Stück.
Man kann übrigens Kartenzahlungen bei mir machen.
Kleiner Tipp, bei dem lokalen Buchhandel ist es günstiger.
Das ist günstiger, aber bei mir gibt es das aus meiner Hand.
Ja, toll.
100 Euro. Toll. Ich bringe mal 10 mit, Taschenbücher. Die Schrift ist eigentlich
zu klein, aber vielleicht geht das so für das Regal zu Hause.
Und dann erscheint ja auch oder ist schon erschienen das Kinderbuch,
das ich zusammen mit Ole geschrieben habe. Das kommt am 12.
August. Kann man also auch vorbestellen.
Die kleinen Holzdiebe und das Rätsel des Yoga-Naut.
Oder was viele Autogramme geben müssen.
Dann gibt es Kapitalismuskritik für Kinder und für die Eltern.
Ich glaube, für die Eltern wird es am Ende wichtiger sein, als für die Kinder.
Die Kinder verstehen es ja intuitiv schon.
Ich bin ja...
Man muss auch, wenn man ein Kinderbuch schreibt, auch daran denken,
dass man den Eltern was mitgibt.
Die Kinder sind ja cleverer meist als die Eltern.
Ich bleibe bei der Idee bei Ole, auch wenn ich die Methode, wie er es vortrug, natürlich nicht teile.
Aber er saß ja auf der Bühne und meinte, wir müssen an die Kinder ran. Ja, und dann hat...
JP, nur kurz. Ja, okay. Kommentiert.
Also ich finde schon, man sollte an die Kinder ran, dass ihr ein Kinderbuch
gemacht habt, das auch für Kinder ist.
Das ist für Kinder, genau.
Nicht verkehrt, man sollte es auch gezielt jetzt nicht wieder wie bei Harry
Potter, ist eigentlich für die Eltern oder so, sondern nein.
Nee, nee, es ist für die Kinder. Und wie gesagt, dann sind wir da.
Also den Salon kann man über Steady buchen. Man kann übrigens auch über Steady
den Salon verschenken, wenn jemand den Salon verschenken will,
an Leute, die dringend solche Inhalte brauchen,
dann ist das auch da über ein Geschenkpaket ganz einfach möglich und man kann
den Salon aber auch über Patreon hören, wenn man dort schon angemeldet ist,
dann kann das vielleicht einfacher sein.
Oder es geht über Apple.
Dort muss man dann glaube ich auch nur auf den Bezahlbutton klicken.
Ja, nur auf Play klicken, zweimal drücken, dass man bezahlt,
fertig. Aber ein bisschen teurer, 50 Cent teurer.
Was bringst du in den Salon mit?
Ah ja, im Salon werde ich nach Blühdorn über Generationengerechtigkeit reden.
Also die vier Seiten, die von einem von der Bundesregierung beauftragten Gremium,
nämlich dem Bundesjugendkuratorium geschrieben wurden, die ich wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr gut finde.
Esra Kleins spektakulärer Text, werden wir durchgehen, es ist wirklich herausragend.
Diesen Vanity Fair Text, den ich mir über eine App, mit der man sich die Texte
anhören kann, jetzt ungefähr fünfmal angehört habe und wirklich beeindruckt
davon bin, wie viel da drin steckt,
werden wir nur kurz umreißen, um dann uns die von Claude rausgesuchten zentralen
programmatischen Punkte, auf die es jetzt ankommt, wissend, dass wir diesen
Typen, um den es in diesem Text geht,
über den 2022 22 geschrieben wurde,
dass wir den heute als Vizepräsidentschaftskandidaten haben. Außerdem,
Ehe-Performance. Wenn es in der Ehe nicht gut läuft, was könnte man dann machen?
Natürlich Freunde fragen, Therapeuten beauftragen oder sich eine App runterladen
und Feedback organisieren, wie in der Arbeitswelt.
Könnte vielversprechend sein in San Francisco, wo sonst in der Zeitung im San
Francisco Standard wurde darüber geschrieben. Ich fand es ganz amüsant.
Ich stelle einen Roman der japanischen Schriftstellerin Hiroko Oyamada vor.
Dieser Roman heißt Das Loch und ist die doch surreal werdende Geschichte einer
Frau, die mit ihrem Mann aufs Land zieht in Japan und dort in der Nähe der Schwiegereltern
lebt und dann geschehen sehr eigenartige Dinge.
Außerdem stelle ich das Buch vor, Opfernationalismus, Erinnerung und Herrschaft
in der postkolonialen Welt von Ji Hyun Lim,
einem koreanischen Historiker, der sich die Erinnerungsdiskurse um Kolonialismus
und Holocaust anschaut und sich fragt, wo beginnt die Relativierung,
wo sind aber Vergleiche angebracht, wo ist auch eine Konfrontation der verschiedenen
Ereignisse angebracht.
Ein Buch, das man lesen sollte, weil es interessante Ansätze gibt,
aber es bleibt auch nicht widerspruchsfrei, bei mir zumindest.
Ich muss doch einiges da anmerken. Dann will ich kurz in einer Meldung darauf
eingehen, wie in der Ukraine mit Deserteuren umgegangen wird.
Dann haben wir einen Text aus
der Financial Times über die Umarmung des Bitcoin seitens Donald Trump.
Was ist da los? Und wer arbeitet eigentlich hinter den KIs?
Netzpolitik.org hat mit einer Soziologin gesprochen, die gerade eine große Initiative
mitorganisiert und mal darüber aufklärt, wer dort arbeitet und was da so verdient wird.
Spoiler, sehr, sehr wenig. Das alles kann man also gleich im Salon hören.
Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr auf diese Weise den Podcast unterstützt und dann bis gleich im Salon.
Warte, Moment, wir müssen noch kurz, wie wir jetzt mit Hörerfeedback umgehen. Ah ja.
Denn ich habe versucht, Claude alle 157 E-Mails, die an mail.neue20er.de geschickt
wurden, seit der Juni-Ausgabe...
Zu geben, sodass mir eine Zusammenfassung gegeben wird und ich bin so halb zufrieden,
denn mal werden so sieben E-Mails aufgegriffen, mal zwölf, wenn ich sage,
ey, es waren noch 157. Ah ja, entschuldige, hier hast du noch drei mehr.
Also es klappt nicht so richtig gut.
Na, die KI ist faul.
Die KI ist sehr faul. Man kann also nur kurz umreißen, dass wir Feedback hatten zum Thema.
Der Podcast ist sehr gut, weil jeder, der uns schreibt, in der ersten Zeile
erst beschreibt, dass der Podcast sehr gut ist.
Deswegen, ich gehe jetzt mal punktuell drauf ein auf so Sachen.
ALP zum Beispiel hat uns uns geschrieben, was ihn fassungslos macht,
ist, dass im Referendariat,
wenn du einen ausländischen Abschluss nachgeholt hast, also hier in Deutschland
nachqualifiziert hast, dann ist dein Referendariat unbezahlt.
Kann das sein?
Ich kann das auch gar nicht glauben, aber es scheint eine Beobachtung aus dem
Felde zu sein. Kann man also mal nachgehen?
Man traut denen ja vieles zu. Wir wissen ja auch, wie viele Schulen Lehrer anstellen,
nur für die Zeit in der sie unterrichten und dann werden sie in den Sommerferien wieder entlassen.
Die bekommen dann keinen bezahlten Urlaub.
Also da ich das Bildungssystem, wie wir auch nachher nochmal hören,
sowieso für nicht mehr existent halte, das ist wie so ein Zug,
der einfach nicht kommt, würde ich sagen, ja, da scheint was dran zu sein.
Also diese Clore-Zusammenfassung kann man, also ich könnte jetzt sozusagen so
da durchgehen, aber mein Vorschlag ist, dieser Telegram-Chat ist als ein Kanal-Chat
natürlich unbrauchbar, stellt sich raus.
Ich richte jetzt im Urlaub für dann im August mal ein Discord-Ding ein.
Wir haben so Podcast-Erfahrungen wie bei Haken dran, die haben dann irgendwie tausende Hörer da drin.
Nicht alle haben Discord-Accounts. Trotzdem kann man da diskutieren.
Sich einen Discord-Account zu machen ist jetzt nicht schwer, kostet auch kein Geld.
Wir hätten dann aber den Vorteil, dass man da relativ viel automatisiert machen
kann, wie zum Beispiel jede E-Mail, die kommt.
Ich würde ja sagen, sie ist an uns beide adressiert. Hat jetzt wirklich jemand
was dagegen, wenn dann auch noch andere Hörer von dieser E-Mail profitieren?
Die kriegen ja teilweise fünf bis zehn.
Manche haben ja schon ihre Adressen oder so angegeben. Ich glaube,
das wollen dann doch Leute nicht.
Ja, wir können natürlich eine E-Mail-Adresse einrichten, bei der absolut klar ist.
Aber man könnte einfach deutlich machen, dass man also Debattenbeiträge dann
bei Discord postet. Oder direkt bei Discord postet.
Und die anderen Sachen, also weiß ich nicht, in direkte Vortragsanfrage oder
so natürlich nicht in Discord reinschreiben, sondern die schreibt man dann direkt
per E-Mail und ich glaube, dass das mit Discord insofern gut ist,
als wir ja sehr viele verschiedene Themen im Podcast ansprechen,
auch manche zeitlose Themen,
wie zum Beispiel KI da haben und dann könnte man das in einzelnen Channels diskutieren
und das soll aber nicht so gedacht sein, dass wir jetzt dort als die Masterminds
nochmal alles ordnen, sortieren und den Diskurs bestimmen,
sondern wir nehmen unsere Podcasts auf und dann gibt's aber die Möglichkeit für alle, die wollen,
die weiter diskutieren wollen oder sich auch vernetzen wollen oder mal treffen
wollen, als kleines Hörertreffen, wo wir gar nicht mit involviert sind,
die Möglichkeit, das über Discord zu organisieren.
Ich glaube, das ist das Sinnvollste, was man darüber machen kann.
Ja, genau. Also wir rückkoppeln im Podcast ist schwierig. Bei Discord das einlaufen
zu lassen, das wäre super.
Ansonsten, ich kann natürlich überlegen, ob ich jetzt das Cloud immer frage,
such mir zumindest alle Fragen, die gestellt wurden und alle Empfehlungen,
irgendwelche Bücher, Filme, wie auch immer, dass man das dann mal strukturiert sammelt.
Aber da würde ich sagen, dann lieber direkt dieser Umweg in diese Semi-Öffentlichkeit,
in so einem Discord-Ding.
Und Discord scheint mir, klar kann man das immer alles selber hosten,
mit Diskurs zum Beispiel.
Aber warum, ehrlich gesagt, ja? Also da kann man ja wirklich Sachen nehmen,
die es schon gibt. Werden wir also einrichten für August.
Und dann mal gucken, wie wir mit E-Mails umgehen. Denn klar,
wenn wir jetzt nach Wahlrechtssachen fragen, das ist alles wahnsinnig hochinteressant.
Wird dann auch in meinem Buch einlaufen. Aber wir haben jetzt 70 E-Mails zum
Thema oder so, ohne dass wir jetzt in der Lage waren, da große Auswertung zu
machen und dann nochmal doppelt so viele E-Mails zu allen anderen Themen.
In der Hinsicht gehen wir da mal in diese Discord-Richtung. Wie so viele Podcasts ja eigentlich.
Discord scheint ja schon so ein Podcast-Feedback- Kanal zu sein. Gut.
Bis gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.